welcome to another exciting episode of
what's in the box I'm Mork Mindy and
we're gonna dive right in this box then
we're hiding things I'm burying the lede
go in there man go deep
once again Jason's using a knot you
forgot this there's usually three sides
and still every week look at this oh
this is classic stuff kids we're gonna
play with some Dick Tracy figures this
week let's get them out of the box
holy cow I haven't seen these since this
movie keep him out of this ill-fated
movie by Warren Beatty my brother let me
take you back on a little trip to town
the years 1990 we haven't even made
Clarke's yet but Batman just rocked the
box office the Tim Burton's Batman where
baby was like hey man this Batman seems
popular I think I'll make a comic book
movie beautiful movie star oh this is a
Disney movie man Warren Beatty makes
this for dizzy that's their idea of like
let's go after the Batman audience as if
it's the same thing whatsoever do you
know anything about it you know he's the
you're the guy I was like gonna watch
yes I'm on my way that reason you wanted
this like hello I'm talking to my phone
is because this guy they did it in the
comic strips like years ago before
anybody was that anywhere close to mega
the two-way watch we need Dick Tracy to
get eventually to Batman and stuff like
that so you know your honor him he's a
link in the chain but this movie was was
misbegotten okay kids what we're looking
at here is a table full of [ __ ]
Dick Tracy figures nobody in the history
of mankind or womankind has ever said I
want a Dick Tracy figure nobody bought
these toys placing [ __ ] vehicles that
watch each sold separately from
playmates the same company that made the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles line and
you know playmates was like we're gonna
make that fat Kenner dollar [ __ ] like
the Star Wars they didn't make anything
look at these figures they're all
bowlegged I want to see being guess
their names turned out looking at I'm
ready I'm gonna cover it
guys this that's his buddy and I forget
his name
yeah prune face itchy
that would be lips man list
you ever see Sex in the City
he's jamala see mr. ho mr. [ __ ] is all
about right there see would you please
just stop calling it that this oh that
is big boy caprese look what you did to
your witty Tom Shean this would be the
[ __ ] this figure was the most famous
toy in this whole dopey line he was a
homeless guy and it says he stick it up
the sores there's stuff writing on the
back like it calls him an ignorant bum
with cava he'll smell him before you see
him then they thought it was cruel to
almost be a corruption of minors hmm
touching homeless advocacy groups
protested and criticized the [ __ ] toy
and it was pulled from shelves this is
the rodent I am this is Dustin Hoffman
mumbles of course that's flat top who is
Dick Tracy's Joker
even though in the movie to get a lot of
screens out they used Al Pacino as the
main villain big boy capris challenge me
we all go there was one Napoleon what
whatsit them want me
what's not reflected here is the
breathless Mahoney figure I was
beginning to wonder what a girl had to
do to get arrested we're in that dress
is a step in the right direction
Madonna played that character in the
Dick Tracy movie but she does some nifty
undercover work as we know even back
then as with the Avengers now they're
like girl figure who'll ever play with
that and it's just dudes spoilers I
don't want to ruin Dick Tracy for you
but spoilers if you haven't seen it wait
a few seconds for five Madonna is the
main villains plays a character called
the blankie don't know you don't know
that till the end of the movie figure
for the villain the blank was made but
it had a removable mask that gave away
the big plot twist
here's her flank dude yeah there it is
but they had to take it out because then
you knew that it was Madonna and you
were like oh Dick Tracy spoiled for me
but I Got News for you
if you watch Dick Tracy was also spoiled
now do you think that the actual figure
the blank he's actually worse I don't
want to take no yeah the black is and I
think the tram I'm not gonna take the
tram packs which of the tramps were the
bucket to dude in the 90s there it is
one two three it's like that commercial
Warren Beatty made everyone a grotesque
everybody's done something to make them
a little bit monstrous Dick Tracy had
this big ass like square block nose in
the comics but Warren Beatty didn't want
to wear that nose so he just had his
normal nose anyone else rare [ __ ]
he made everyone else put [ __ ] on her
face because that's what Warren Beatty
does
playmates just took the molds from some
Turtles figures and then made different
heads that's why they're a bowlegged
Lecter hi I could see Ravi Oliver I hear
it a little
right here I could see Rocksteady but
the good news is in since it's in the
playmates world if you're a Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles fan you can
suddenly have more guest stars than they
ever had like hey Warren Beatty's showed
up in the sewers look at that that
doesn't look like Warren Beatty this
figure wouldn't get laid by millions not
this guy this bowlegged like I'm Dick
Tracy man that whole Dick Tracy thing
was just a bunch of people didn't know
the genre they didn't know they were
just like oh Dick Tracy Batman worked so
of course Dick Tracy would even the toys
they were like I whatever the toys can
look like [ __ ] kids will buy them they
buy anything [ __ ] the kids stood up
and Massimo like [ __ ] your toys suck my
dick
Tracy we know why they didn't have the
courage to try for this they might never
tried the Avengers or the x-men I'll
tell you right now the best thing comes
out of this man right here
you get yourself a lips man list that's
a Paul Sorvino action figures character
Tracy and honestly who wants to play
pictures with this you could finally be
like now I got to turn my back on you
now I got a Diamondback like he gives
you a couple hundred bucks after a
lifetime that's all I got he turns
around it goes back to cooking a sausage
and you could use the Joe Pesci figure
from the home alone line yes and there
it is you're playing good fuzz if we
could just get a Ray Liotta figure going
laptop dude it is probably the most
visually interesting of all the Dick
Tracy character this is a dude who's
just right for the job you know what I'm
saying cuz if he's down on his knees in
front of you could put your ashtray
right on top yeah yeah bags yes yeah why
would you grab a ax be on top of a said
a few dick is in his mouth you don't
want to put your dick heads mouth you
just write your nuts to rest on some
it's second ho so you're just like my
ultimate is dignity you kneel down rough
my nuts on your fly this guy comes with
a yeah that could take a blackjack yeah
he's loud to him they barely fit in
their head this dude has a noose this is
real justice right here alright so these
guys all come with tommy guns billy
clubs pipes which is exactly what you
want your kids playing with like hey mom
i'm playing with my toys at the end one
of them will hang the other foreign
justices even batman doesn't do that
this guy i remember in the movie had the
only memorable line i still remember to
this day he says 30 seconds no more dick
cuz they set a bomb and he was running
out of room he goes thirty seconds no
more dick thirty seconds no more dick is
what my wife says to me whatever i'm
finishing up this alright how much would
you pay for this crap my friend each
figure yeah in the day i would say there
were 999 excellent paul they were not on
you know 99 how much you think they go
for it today well being that i said hey
let's be shouldn't open these for 99 no
399 they went for three to five bucks
apiece each on ebay is $50 the screen
junkies will never get back this blank
figure that's missing the one that like
is the good one the madonna figure if
all these go for three to five bucks
piece how much you think the black goes
for on eBay mmm it's hard to find we
don't have it here I'd say 200 bucks
like if you think out loud that's good
that's smart sometimes you guys say
things out loud help you solve through
it like I think I could do this Tom
bucks
you're wrong $450 oh right Wow like when
is Madonna been that valuable like ever
in recent years that's crazy remember we
talked about the [ __ ] yes how we're
like they pulled this from shelves so I
assumed that this would be more valuable
than the rest three bucks three bucks so
we could totally take it out the box
let's take let him let's do something no
kid has ever done
movie night [ __ ] with the rest of the
toy man he was taken off shelves now
he's like yeah we're all friends
together yes
so was my balls [ __ ] you
and he hits him over to having a [ __ ]
piece of plywood and he's done you live
in a really hostile world man it's got a
little hole in the shoe
where's toe sticking out is that that's
and that is justice you know in terms of
opening the box and finding things I'm
happy we did this but it reminds me of a
different time altogether time when they
as you pointed out before it was no
Avengers no what's the first successful
comic movie was it x-men no you go back
to Superman dick down or Superman and
then you got after that couple years
goes quiet and then Tim Burton's Batman
then Schumacher killed Batman and then
everyone went running from comic book
movies first one step back I believe was
blade I think blade was the first movie
where it's like yeah it's based on a
comic and it's pretty badass and then
x-men that did well then next was
spider-man and that was the rebirths
people like me who were back in the
comic book game and then Marvel came
into the scene the Iron Man for women oh
the rest is history but this is from a
dark period this is the dark ages of
history right here if we're living in
the Renaissance this is the Dark Age
look at this tall Florence departure you
know what Dolph Lundgren's Punisher is a
little more like accurate and I could
sit through that again before I could
sit through this was this before the
Phantom
they're definitely contemporaries this
was based on an actual well the comic
strips the one that you open up in the
papers on Sunday morning you're like
Snoopy the far side and you skip to Dick
Tracy and they made the whole movie
about this it wasn't the fan I'm a comic
strip as well it was what's your point
why keep bringing shovin phantom down my
throat my point is they decided to make
this movie before they made the phantom
movie when they were both comics show
that movie yeah good point they did but
honestly that I would make before Dick
Tracy because like that's a dude
punching people and it did the mask
adventure and stuff this is like setting
up like the 20s the depression and stuff
but without Dick Tracy having all his
rogues gallery that's where Batman gets
rogues alleys from he out of first IFIF
I remember correctly thank you Dick
Tracy yeah respect for what went before
very well now let's [ __ ] on it a little
bit more freeze
you three
that's five minutes into the movie then
he's like I'm gonna get this he grabs
this do you think you got a nice purple
suit and a nice mustache oh I got a bag
of money I'll pay you this bag of money
to come all over my friends face and it
gives him the money and then he goes
onion this dude comes over you put the
dick and Dick Tracy my friend I'll tell
you that much
hey Sam eg but [ __ ] come over to help me
on his watch cuz he has to cool off so
you become Zoey's Academy get this - he
goes hey come here it shoves the [ __ ]
stick right up his bunghole
this dude's the last one here he's like
I'm the only guy here with classes I
can't see [ __ ] and he was [ __ ] mrs.
Lacey comes over Tracy gets them yeah
puts his ball bag right on his mouth
glasses the end
you know what honestly that was better
than the Dick Tracy movie they should
have given you the reins look at that
we've seen some crap come out the box
this ranks right down there with the
crap but I was happy to see it again man
you know why reminder that I didn't fall
for this [ __ ] cuz I bought everything
dude but for some reason I was like I'm
not gonna invest in Dick Tracy see how
it goes
look at this I'm just happy I never
bought it I'm happy I get to play with
it I said to wait 26 years and I get to
play with him without having to pay for
it yes [ __ ] you Warren Beatty yeah I win
you like seeing us play with things that
nobody wants right into the screen
junkies man at the Twitter account at
their Facebook page wherever get in
touch with them carrier pigeon any
smokes Ingalls stuff like that just get
to them and tell them what you want us
to open up what you want us to reveal
right here on what's in the box
that's it for what's in the box kids I'm
Kevin Smith come back next week man will
tell you what's in the box what's in the
box
you
you